hello everyone my name is laura ann
lowry i'm an associate professor at
boston university school of medicine in
the department of medicine in section of
hematology and medical oncology i am
very grateful for this opportunity to
tell you about the research in my lab
and so i want to thank the organizers of
this conference for inviting me to speak
to you today
so the big picture research question
that has fascinated me in my lab for as
long as i can remember
is how do cells move
how do they find their way
how does this cell move towards the
right direction whatever that may be
and away from the wrong direction
now this is a fundamental question in
cell biology cell movement happens in
the embryo during development it happens
in the adult during
wound healing and the immune response
and it happens inappropriately during
cancer metastasis
errors involving cell movement can have
disastrous consequences with a variety
of pathological situations
and this is especially true for cell
movement during embryonic development
constructing the embryo involves an
elaborate orchestration of both
collective and individual cell movements
many different cell types have to
migrate over a complex embryonic terrain
to get to where they need to be for a
proper tissue assembly and organ
formation
the developing nervous system which is
where most of my lab's research has been
focused
neurons have at least two migration
challenges
each neuron
first is born in a particular location
and then has to migrate
to a different location where then it is
its home for the rest of of uh
rest of the embryo's life the rest of
the organism's life
and then after this movement after this
migration process each neuron then sends
out an extension of itself called an
axon
and sends it over long embryonic
distances to make those essential
connections to wire up the nervous
system with accuracy and precision
now defects in this process of
connectivity lead to a long list of
neurodevelopmental disorders including
we now think it contributes to autism
schizophrenia
when forming these essential neural
connections the primary player in this
process is the growth cone
this is the dynamic hand-like structure
at the tip of the growing axon
it's the growth cones job to find its
target
my lab focuses on how it moves in the
right direction
now this movement that the growth cone
exhibits any movement really
is a mechanical process
there is a machine inside these growth
cones that propels them forward and
steers in the right direction
and this machine is called the
cytoskeleton
in primary embryonic growth cones there
are two major components of the growth
cone cytoskeleton there's actin which
drives motility movement of the growth
cone and then there are microtubules
which provide the organization of the
growth cone and allow for steering
now my lab focuses on how this machine
is controlled which is a
a long-standing question in the growth
cone cytoskeletal field
and what my lab uses is the model
systems benefits latest to tackle this
question
with this system
we can easily inject constructs for
de-manipulation into the early embryos
the next day we can dissect out the
neural tubes
culture them
on cover slips
and then the following day axons have
grown out here you can see the axons
emanating from a neural tube explant
if we zoom in to just a single growth
cone
their large and impressive growth cones
allow for clear visualization of
individual microtubules as well as
complexes protein complexes that are
found on microtubules
there may be no other vertebrate model
system that has primary embryonic growth
cones as large and as easy and
inexpensive to culture manipulate an
image as xenopus lavish and that's why i
chose this model system for my lab's
work
in my lab we study a number of different
projects related to cell movement so i'm
going to just give you a brief overview
of them now as i mentioned the major
focus of my lab's work is studying the
growth cone and in this context we study
microtubule regulators and how they play
a role in axon guidance and again this
has been the major focus of my research
i'm going to talk about this top two
different
vignettes within this topic after the
introduction
but my lab is also diversified and
looking at other different research
areas that are related so we also now
look at neural crest cell migration
within the context of a human disorder
called wolf-hershon syndrome which i'm
going to talk about at the end of this
talk
and we're also now using xenopus latest
neural crest cells as a model to study
cancer metastasis
finally
we are also using xenopus lavis as
an
rather inexpensive medium throughput
system to identify genes
the functions of genes associated with
various human intellectual disability
disorders
so it's a broad range of topics all
related to either cell movement or
neural development and today i'm going
to talk about the microtubule
regulator's nexon guidance and will
first run syndrome
so first
let's go back to this growth cone this
dynamic structure at the tip of the
growing axon
as i mentioned it's the growth cones job
to find its target it needs to make
decisions
whether to move forward to retract or to
turn i told you this movement is a
mechanical process and so there is a
machine
called the cytoskeleton inside the
growth cone
in order for the growth cone
cytoskeletal machine to move in the
correct direction
there have to be various cues
that the growth cone encounters both
negative guidance cues positive guidance
cues that then are somehow translated
to
converge upon the cytoskeleton so that
the cytoskeleton then grows in the right
direction and moves the growth cone in
one direction or another
so we zoom in to a cartoon of this
growth cone
you have red actin filaments in this
cartoon in the periphery and again
they're driving growth cone motility
and then there are microtubules in blue
which both form the core of the axon
shaft as well as they there's dynamic
microtubules that explore the growth
cone periphery they even go into these
these filopodia move along f actin
bundles
and these microtubules can perform this
internal growth cone exploration
by utilizing their property of dynamic
instability where microtubules switch
between growing phases and shrinking
phases
and by rapidly switching between these
two states they can effectively explore
the entire growth cone periphery and
even go into those filopodia
and that's where the guidance cues are
first going to be detected
now on the the tips of these
microtubules
there are a series of proteins called
plus and tracking proteins or plus tips
here in this this
microscopy image you can have the plus
tip in green with microtubules in red
and you can see it forms these comet
shaped accumulations on the ends of the
microtubules
now plus tip activity is directly
modulated by upstream kinase signaling
not only do plus tips bind to and
regulate microtubules but they also
interact with structures such as f-actin
and cell adhesions and so it seems quite
plausible that plus tips might take a
central role in orchestrating the growth
cone response to guidance cues
but the data for how this might occur
are largely unknown as pleasant
interaction and function with the
nervous system has not been extensively
examined and so that's where my lab came
in so back when i was still a postdoc at
harvard medical school i did a screen to
identify new microtubular regulators
that could be plus tips that might be
playing a role within the growth cone to
promote axon guidance it was a very
fruitful screen i used drosophila it's a
great screening platform identified a
number of potential microtubule
regulators the two that i'm going to be
focused on for this talk are x-map 215
and tac-3
it's been known for over a decade that
these two proteins bind to each other
and interact to regulate cell division
but there was little known about their
their functions during neural
development when i studied them
x-map 215 is is also called c-h-tog in
humans or c-cap 5.
now x-map 215 a lot was known about this
decades of work xmap was known as the
classic microtubule polymerase it would
bind tubulin dimers in the cytoplasm as
well as the end of microtubules the plus
end
and it would deposit those tubulin
dimers onto the plus end to promote
microtubule growth
thus it functioned as a catalytic
microtubule polymerase
it was also highly enriched at the
centrosome from where most from where
most microtubules nucleate and it's
thought that it's there so that exomap
213 could then load on to new
microtubules to promote their growth
what i'm going to tell you about today
though
is a new function for x-map-215
where it is more than simply microtubule
polymerase
now this work was spearheaded by a
postdoc in my lab paula slater as well
as a graduate student garrett camarata
and they had the help of two undergrads
annika and ali
when paula joined my lab she wanted to
explore uh an
unexpected finding uh for xmap 215
knocks down growth cones so i found that
when we knocked down x-map 215 this
catalytic microtubule polymerase but
only knocked it down partially like 50
we didn't get rid of it completely just
partially
we saw that the growth cones were larger
now this made little sense so in this in
this image you can see the green art is
actin
which forms like the size of the growth
cone and red are the microtubules
and when pollen measured
the these growth cones she found that
when x-map 215 was partially knocked
down the growth cones were larger and
the filopodia were longer
and she could rescue this by adding back
full length x-map 215 suggesting that
this defect was specific to x-map 215
knockdown
this made little sense why knocking down
a microtubule polymerase would lead to
larger growth cones longer filopodia
filled with actin
we wanted to know well could x-map-215
be somehow affecting f actin
now in a movie that i had taken you
could see the still image where xmap 215
this is a growth cone
you could see that it forms these puncta
at the ends of microtubules but also you
could see it along the microtubule
lattice the side of the microtubule
this led us to wonder well
in order for microtubules to grow along
these f-actin bundles
the so the f actin is also undergoing a
process called retrograde flow you can
see this in the bottom left cartoon
where actin is flowing backwards towards
the center of the growth tone but the
microtubules are moving forward but if
the microtubules are going to be
moving along the f actin using them as
guides there has to be transient
frequent coupling and uncoupling
regulation of the interaction between
microtubules and effects and we wondered
could xmf215 be playing a role in this
interaction
so apollo looked
at the alignment of the microtubules to
these f-actin bundles
and she found that with the x-map 215
knock-down condition
there was a reduction in the percentage
of microtubules that were aligned to f
actin again this could be rescued by
adding back x and up to 15. and if she
overexpressed x map 215 there was an
increase
in the number of microtubules that were
aligned to the f-actin and so this
suggested that yes indeed x-map-215 can
affect microtubule alignment with
f-actin in growth counts
so she wanted to know well what what
part of x-map 215 was facilitating this
interaction so this is a cartoon of
x-men it's a big protein it's 215
kilodaltons there's a number of domains
there are five tog domains tog stands
for tumor over express gene and there's
a c term domain
and so she made a series of of deletion
constructs to see which domains could
rescue
the xmap 215 knockdown microtubule
f-actin alignment defect and here's a
busy graph what you can see from this is
i'm going to focus your attention on
this is what it looks like when the full
length x215 is expressed there's a full
rescue
of the
alignment defect but when she looked at
all these various constructs none of
them could rescue like the full length
except for this tog one to five so tog
one to four was not sufficient
and so the difference between top one to
four and tug one to five is not only the
fifth top domain but also this
microtubule lattice binding region
and that led us to wonder perhaps
something in this region is allowing the
microtubules
to to interact with with effect and
through binding to x-map 215 on this
lattice
but we wanted to know this was the very
first time maximum 215 had been
associated with f actin
so can it actually bind f-actin in vitro
is this even possible
so to to test this
garrett my phd student used an f-actin
sedimentation assay where he combined
polymerized f-actin along with purified
x-mep 215 protein and then combine them
together spun them down anything that
bound to the pellet
was
binding to f-actin and anything the
supernatant
was not binding to fact and what he
found was that indeed
x-map 215 could directly bind to f-actin
and vitro you can see as the levels of
f-actin go up there's increasing levels
of x-map 215 in the pellet okay and this
shows very strong binding to f actin
and so this is the full length and so of
course the next question is what domains
of xmph215 facilitate this interaction
with f actin
and so again we did deletion construct
analysis the c term domain was not
sufficient to bind to f action you could
see there's almost no x map 215 c term
in the pellet in this in this image
the tog one to four was not sufficient
for strong binding to the pel to the f
actin very littles in the pellet but the
tug one to five the same construct that
could rescue the microtubule effect and
alignment defect was sufficient to bind
to f-actin in vitro
and so what i've shown you and so you
can see this nice binding curve so what
i've shown you in terms of the new
function for x and f 215
that partial x map 215 knockdown leads
to larger growth tones and to be honest
we still don't understand why the growth
cones are larger okay
we we need to look into that more deeply
but what this this uh phenotype
suggested for us is that if actions
could be playing a role and so then we
went further to this to determine that x
max25 could promote microtubule f action
and growth counts
we then also determined that x-map 215
can directly bind to effect in in vitro
and this is facilitated by the tog one
to five domain
we're still working on xbox 215 trying
to figure out what it's doing and how
it's regulated but at this time i'm
going to turn to a related story on tac
renet tac 3 is a a primary interactor of
x-map 215.
and when we when we first started
setting it because i just want to
mention this worked on tax iii was
spearheaded by my phd student berjou and
she had the support of two undergrads
ben and eric
so when we first started studying tact
three tech three was not
um was not in the literature as a plus
tip it was a centrosome adapter and its
main microtubule function was to bring
x-map-215 the polymerase of microtubules
to centrosomes like this main function
according to the literature was just as
a recruitment factor but we wondered if
maybe taxes could be acting as a direct
plus tip and it could be directly
regulating microtubule plus and dynamics
more directly than simply recruiting
xmap
so we
first just expressed gfp tag tag 3 and
saw that indeed tach3 could be
functioning as a plus tip here you can
see a montage in the bottom of a single
microtubule where tach3 in green is it
that is the tip of the growing
microtubule
we found that
manipulating tact refunction leads to
changes in microtubule growth velocity
so when we partially knock down tach3
there's a reduction in the velocity of
microtubule growth and when we
overexpress tach3
there is a slight increase in the
velocity of microtubule growth the
lifetime of the microtubules were not
affected so the catastrophe frequency
wasn't affected just the polymerization
rate
now consistently with this effect on
microtubules brazil found that when she
reduced tachy levels there was a
reduction in the length of the axons
that grew out when there was an increase
in temporary levels there was an
increase in the axon outgrowth and this
was all expected for a microtubule
polymerase promoter
what was fascinating though
is when uh bergeron looked at time-lapse
imaging
she saw that overexpressing tac-3
led to a mild reduction in accent
outgrowth velocity this made no sense
if we are over expressing a microtubule
polymerase and the axons end up being
longer why would they grow out more
slowly how could that be
when she looked at the data more closely
she noticed that in controlled
situations
axons growing on laminin coated
coverslips in vitro
they undergo spontaneous retraction at a
certain frequency and when taxi was
overexpressed
the axons reduced their spontaneous
retraction rates
thus these axons even though they were
growing more slowly they grew more
persistently over time and that is how
they end up having longer axons
now this was interesting to us and we we
wanted to know more about
whether taxi could be mediating accident
outgrowth in response to guidance cues
so
what brazil did is she applied
slit 2 which is normally a repulsive
factor and she found that
normally when you add slit 2 to
the media of these axons there's a
collapse of the rocks and you can't see
it the movie isn't playing but if you if
you were watching the movie you'd see
the axon would be collapsing
what she found is that when taxi was
overexpressed
there was a reduction in the growth cone
collapse phenotype thus this data
demonstrated to us that tax free was
somehow mediating the growth cone
response to guidance few such as slip
we wondered well we wanted to know more
about the signaling pathway involved and
so the first candidate we looked at was
ableton tyrosine kinase it's known that
able mediate split signaling we wanted
to know could ableton tyrosine kinase be
directly indirectly or directly
phosphorylating tact three and so to do
this work we joined forces with a
collaborator of mine brian ballas at the
university of vermont
he's a mass back and kinase expert what
we found is that when we express tack
ray gfp as well as ableton tyrosine
kinase in heck 293 cells there was this
really nice phosphotyrosine signal
we sent that off from mass back there
were a number of candidates the number
of tyrosines that were phosphorylated
both in the attack domain as well as a
highly conserved regulatory domain
and so we wanted to know if we knocked
those out you know could it affect the
function of path3
when she knocked it out first she did a
western and surprisingly saw that the
phospho-tyrosine signal was not changed
at all so then she knocked out the other
uh possible tyrosines it could be
phosphorylated did a western again after
expressing them and again there was
still a phosphotyrosine signal which
again was surprising so then she decided
well there's other tyrosines in tech
three and maybe they're being
phosphorylated you know when these when
some of the tyrosines are missing so
then she decided to focus on just attack
domain which is sufficient to drive
polymerization and there are six
tyrosines there so she made phosphonols
all fixed again she did the expression
analysis and the uh western and she saw
surprisingly that there was still a
fossil tyrosine signal despite the fact
that there were no tyrosines left intact
but then she realized that we were
expressing gfp attack not just tac gfp
also has tyrosines so when she expressed
just gfp alone
she found that when able was
co-expressed gfp could be phosphorylated
and this is something that's really
important for me to share with you
because i didn't realize that gfp could
be phosphorylated and it isn't in the
literature anywhere so this is something
that people should keep in mind if
they're doing these sorts of experiments
but we still have this hack phosphor
knowledge and she wanted to know does
the fossil null change tax function
and here what she did was she expressed
tac uh both the wild type tech as well
as tax phosphonol and she found that
under uh control conditions you know
wild type tack most of it bound to the
microtubule but the attack phosphonol
most of it found on most of it did not
bind the microtubule and instead was
stuck in the cytoplasm
okay so to summarize what i shared for
you about new tax refunction
first
bonding to microtubules to promote their
polymerization
too much tax rate leads to microtubule
growth despite the repulsive cues and
reduced acid retraction and less leading
to longer axons and that attack
phosphonol cannot bind as well to
microtubules so kinase signaling does
indeed affect tech's ability to bind to
microtubules and regulate external
guidance
and future studies in my lab are
continuing to dissect the mechanisms by
which tac-3 is regulated during growth
guidance
now in the last uh you know a few
minutes of my talk i want to turn to
another area of research in my lab uh
looking at wolf horse run syndrome
now this relates to neurocrystals so i'm
going to give you a brief introduction
to them
neurocrest cells are a multi-potent
migratory embryonic cell type that they
laminate from the neural tube during
development and they migrate throughout
the embryo and become craniofacial
structures heart
skeletal muscle peripheral neurons
many different cell types and this work
was spearheaded by a former phd in my
lab beth pierce
now we became interested in this
disorder will fortune syndrome
when
we realized that tax rate which we were
studying in the in the context of axon
guidance for some time we learned the
tactic was also deleted in this human
disorder called wolferson syndrome or
whf there's a number of genes missing in
this disorder it's a hemisphygus
mutation
and the embryonic function of most of
these genes was unknown
the defects these children have are
craniofacial heart skeletal cognitive
function defects a number of these
defects could involve a defect in neural
crest cell migration so we wondered if
it could be a neurocrystal migration
disorder so we decided to test that by
looking at the functions of these
different genes expression and the
effect on knockdown
so first we found that most of these
associated genes are expressed at least
in part in neural crest cells and so
here on the left you can see a
neurocrystal marker and it forms uh it
stains these pharyngeal arches on the
side with you can see it's pointing to
with the arrowheads
and we're looking at the side views of
these heads of these um embryon xenopus
embryos and the big blob that you can
see are the eyes and these pharyngeal
arches which form various craniofacial
structures on the side and most of these
genes are at least partially expressed
in these pharyngeal arches suggesting
they are expressed in the right place to
be playing a role in neural crest cells
when we knocked each of them down
individually we found that they also
impacted not an impact of craniofacial
morphology facial width and midface area
are here but they affected other
parameters as well
we also found that they could affect the
migration of the pharyngeal arches so
when we only knock down
one side of the embryo with either whs1
or tach3 you can see that the pharyngeal
arches are reduced in size and we
wondered could it be because the
pharyngeal arches can't the cells can't
migrate as far so to test this we
dissected out the neural crest cells and
plated them and then measured motility
parameters
we found that indeed knocking down whf
c1 reduces neurocrystal motility in
vitro as well as knocking down tac-3
we did a number of other uh assays which
i don't have time to talk about today um
but what we found is that numerous genes
in this region contribute to various
aspects of craniofacial patterning so
all of them were expressed in the neural
crest cells
when we knock all of them down we see
various defects in facial morphology
we see defects in cartilage morphology
in when we knock down two of them
when we see defects in infrared arch
length and neural crest cell migration
when we knock down two of them
and then we also see defects in four
brain size so they they contribute to
different aspects of craniofacial
patterning
and continued work in my lab is now
investigating well how does tac-3
specifically affect neurocrystal
motility but that's an answer for the
future
so to summarize what i presented
to you today
first i i hope that i've been able to
convey that xenopus lavis is a fantastic
embryonic cell model a model system to
for study cell migration various various
contexts
eczema 215 not only is the microtubule
polymerase but it also can couple or
align microtubule growth microgrowth
microtubules with f-actin tac 3 is a
plus tip that promotes
microtubularization during axon
outgrowth and guidance
i've also
shown you works showing that tax iii
likely contributes to the whs phenotype
along with the other candidate genes
and
the current focus of research in my lab
moving forward is studying how taxi
specifically promotional crystal
migration and also i didn't
tell you about two projects looking at
how collective cell movements are
regulated as well as we're now
transitioning to using benefits as a
model system to study individual
melanoma metastasis
with that i want to acknowledge those
who contribute to this work
first
i have select lab alumni bath brazil
garrett paula and sung look they all did
most of the the work that i showed you
today my current lab members you're
headed by my lab manager mackenzie at
home and many students in my lab i'm
very fortunate to work with a number of
great collaborators the xenopus
community is indebted to the national
census resource as well as zenbase which
provides benefits resources for us
and i appreciate the funding that as has
supported all this work over the years
so i want to thank you very much for
your attention if you have uh questions
for me i definitely welcome you to email
me at la lowry at bu.edu find my website
online
and thank you for your attention